okay four people joining this livestream
this is a little experiment of ours
talking about some issues that have been
reported by users about off language
things people think we should fix and we
want to hear about those so we're going
to cover a bunch of different topics
here um and hopefully we're going to
have hopefully we have some good experts
to discuss these topics so I'm not gonna
talk about these yet I'm I don't think
unless unless we where should I start
should I start here or should I start on
the import-export issues you can dive
right into the import-export issues this
is survivor okay all right okay
many of the importers exports are
working with ancient versions okay
well like what that's not I don't know I
mean the it's a challenging thing with
with import/export because our ability
to test depends on you know if if we're
exporting to something if there's a
format that supposedly works like such
and such but it is primarily consumed by
three different products in many
different versions it's not a trivial
thing for us to have tested those
appropriately you know many many
companies we have arrangements to test
things either they have our software to
test compatibility or we have their
software to test compatibility but it's
not an easy to achieve thing um in in
general and I you know without more
specificity it's really hard to know why
we're hearing budget tightening here but
without more specificity it's really
hard to know I want to say that and
Charlie's here too at that
has been a lot of updates the activity
the development activity in
import/export has ramped up
significantly the last few years and
there was a lot of things that that
speak to what this user says that there
were older formats like Excel for
instance was an important example of a
newer version that needed to be properly
supported all the way which is done
right and I think things like CSV were
not very efficient and they're now
hopeful right maximally efficient so
actually in for many versions now
there's been quite a lot activity in
both addressing things like this as well
as expanding out because the other
things that's changed is the objects
inside of the Wolfram language so we can
do a better job and make you know as a
user you become much more efficient if
you get the object that's sort of ready
to go where you workflow so much more
efficient as opposed to UPC for example
being able to import things as datasets
I'm making sure that we export data sets
maybe shoddy maybe you can say something
about the the data set a lot of that has
already come for spreadsheet for
instance but we are speaking out to see
for instance time series data set and
other types of richer formats that we're
introducing in the system where they are
useful as an import format or important
element and to what formats we can
export them some activities have been
has been done and completed as you said
CSV and Excel is being greatly improved
and some more is to come okay so with
respect to PDF export that's that's
John's area is that correct yeah yeah
so I mean the general story behind PDF
exports is that in version 10 we
completely gutted and replaced PDF
export system it used to be you know a
spoke PDF exporter and we replaced it
and this goes to the front end we
replaced it
with an open-source system called Cairo
that basically you can issue drawing
commands to and among other things it
can then convert those drawing commands
to PDF and also SVG so we did SVG and
any PS at the same time each of those
three go through the Cairo system the
there are two kinds of issues that are
typically reported well three kinds of
issues are typically report with PDF so
the first issue is a problem that also
happens to be a printing problem because
creating PDF looks a lot it looks a lot
like printing and so in some cases you
just try the same thing printing and
nobody thought to do that and you see
the same issue so the second sort of
issue is you know as some issue just
with you know exporting PDF directly in
our code maybe some support that people
want like one of the things which we've
been working on is trying to get
hyperlinks to be active in PDF and
that's a thing that hadn't been done
before I think it my think it exists in
some form in version 12 but it's not one
or a percent complete coverage if I
recall correctly so it but you know
people want to be a deal and not only
see hyperlinks but click on them inside
the PDFs and then and you know other
sorts of limitations which are typically
our issue or occasionally a Kairos issue
and then the third kind of problem is
people want us to put you know send
something to PDF which PDF just as a
format doesn't support very well 3d
graphics we have to emit 3d graphics as
bitmaps PDF because PDF is not a rich
enough format to supports you know the
content model 3d rendering and we you
know we you can adjust the
resolution of the bitmap that we put in
but some people wished we would go back
to doing a vector description even if
maybe it looks worse you know we get
that comment occasionally but but it's
you know it would lose you know all the
modern feature support so right well so
ok but but but what is the ok what I
brought up here is a bunch of PDF bugs
yeah this this is a view into the
internal bugs database we're
experimenting with an open external
database which you can maybe talk about
later but these are internally reported
issues and some may be also externally
reported I don't it's not possible to
tell from this view sorry go ahead
you know not all these bugs have been
entirely vetted I mean there are you
know I'm not a bunch of priority 0 well
you know I'm spotting one bug report
here just right off top my head which I
suspect is not a bug at all but a
misunderstanding on the part of the
reporter and there may be a few others
that are like that too ok so my question
is is is PDF export a currently active
area yes
I mean PDF import is also a currently
active area that's a whole different
story
right that's not in my team or my Lit
kind of intersects with my team but it's
not principally with my site so I mean
my main complaint about PDF export and
this comes up in cloud printing for
example because the cloud has a export
to PDF it's it's analog of printing is
export to PDF um you know my big problem
is that the styles don't look very good
you know if I take a random notebook
like this one for instance I send it to
the cloud right I publish it to the
cloud and then I am you know look at
that notebook in PDF
I think it's styles are wrong I think
the you know the sizing should be
different now it's not we may have done
a faithful job at translating to PDF but
it doesn't look the same as on-screen
well it definitely
doesn't look the same as sunscreen
because PDF is a page oriented format
and since it is a page oriented format
we've made a design decision to treat it
as as if you were printing and print oh
yeah and it's kind of I just use
different styles the sizes are wrong I
think we should you know this is the old
story of you know the windows 80% rule
or whatever it is for printing yeah and
you know I don't know whether we've done
that correctly and I think we need to
look at that again um there's a few
comments on the chat system a when I
checked into ok so Lucas is saying um
another issue is video export formats
but that's that's yes that's very much
coming and Charlie can speak actually
there are a lot of them coming already
in 12 1
can I run now and 12-1 if I in my twelve
one here can I run them no I mean in
prototype yeah okay so I write why not
what fun okay is there something I can
actually see I haven't seen these yet we
haven't reviewed them yet no um this is
actually how well is it
I'm not sure about exporting manipulates
but I'm positive if you explore the list
of images to mp4 in your prototype okay
so let's try that so let's say I go um
so what should i do I should say
something like um graphics of you know
there's a table where they have a list
of image so you want to do a table right
table off something
we release Steven I just a second
um no I was going to just do this I was
going to say disk of radius R zero zero
ha image size no plot range arrow ten
okay all right so if I just say list
animate of this alright I will get this
thing right and so now can I take this
list animate output or do I take the
table output sorry I would do the table
output but I'm getting some compression
level error in my build I don't know
which build you have but there's custom
before yep yeah same thing there these
are in the lower level and we are in the
process of integrating them into import
and export I've tested them at the
packet level what formats we're going to
support mp4 macro score a lot of
encoders for each one of them as far as
what formats we are documenting it's not
going to be that many but there are a
lot of encoding for each one of those
and how do we pick the encoder for a
given for a given set of to give them
content there is gonna be a default most
of them is gonna be h.265 h.264 h.265
but doesn't it depend whether it's
smooth stuff or whether it's lots got
lots of hard edges don't we want to do
some kind of little machine learning
thing to figure out which is the most
likely encoder to work well possibly not
for first version okay but that seems
like a good direction to see is it a
smooth thing
here's the thing with lots of hard edges
okay but anyway bottom line there sounds
like I'm happy to say that the video
format story is going to be solved um
that's great and I think but I think
that the I mean I would say that
import/export is an area where we really
depend on testers and users to report
things because you know it's a jungle
out there
we're not responsible for how something
which we think is a perfectly to spec
version of some format you know actually
reads into some other program that
doesn't quite accept you know all the
tentacles of that format now and one of
the issues which we've run into with PDF
for example is that there's Adobe
Acrobat which is tempting to say is the
golden standard but you know lots of
people view PDF through pre the preview
app on Macintosh or through Chrome and
you know those are renders that you know
are subtly different sometimes and we've
had bugs you know I know specific to the
preview app on on Mac OS I know we've
had bug specific to that and we do have
fairly large import-export test Suites
just I mean we know it sounds a little
bit like we're leaving everything up to
the user to report issues but you know
we do somewhat comprehensive testing in
many areas yeah I mean it just yes we
certainly try um but you know some
formats are just insanely complicated
like PDF is probably one of the more you
know complicated one soon alright anyway
so I think we have I'm happy to say in
this case we have pretty good answer so
um gosh I wish I knew how do you
pronounce but how do you pronounce that
name I'm sorry I'm about to him but I
think it's Szabolcs okay Sabo is saying
on a live stream that he would just set
it to the highest quality for video
output and re-encode later for pilots to
lodge I'm not sure you'll agree with
that once you actually start trying it
because if you're starting to generate
gigabytes sized files my guess is that
you actually want to keep the data
smaller you know within our system I
don't know
shoddy wants to comment on that sorry
what was that again
it doesn't matter look okay um all right
so for it just for rounding up
import-export can I paste a link on the
zoo chatter okay so we do track every
one of those you know externally
reported issues you click on that link
okay well but but actually Szabolcs is
saying annoying bug with PDF of mac
preview app oh yeah exported array plot
ends up blurry that drives me crazy who
understands that that's been a bug
because you know I'm a cellular
Thomasson enthusiast and that's just
dumb let's look at that bug for a second
okay
well what's that here I can well you can
find the bug but I'm gonna just generate
it okay so let's say this and I then
just do an export of that to what I want
to say test dot PDF I have no idea what
directly this is saving and I'll
probably want to UM okay and now I say
system open of that right look at that
that's just crazy
look at that thing what the heck I mean
this used to be a bug in the image
operator in PostScript so it's it's
perfect so yeah I'm not I I think this
is a bug in the image operator I lost I
knew I'm not a hundred well I am is it
I'm not sure that it uses the image
operator well let's look at the
PostScript let's just look at it I mean
it we can look at the actual if I say
file print of pesto PDF I'm not mistaken
I should see it
yeah well it's some of it is compressed
so I'm not sure let's see there is okay
yeah no there is an image operator in
here I'm pretty sure that's the bug cuz
I this bug has been that for at least 20
years and I mean it's a postscript
related bug all right I put a few links
on no no soon well Steven you can't say
it's been there for at least 20 years
because Mac OS preview isn't 20 years
old I understand but this issue about
fuzzing out of image operators is an
issue that's that I've seen for at least
20 years okay but but you know looking
at in Acrobat under Windows it's crystal
clear well look at an eye-opener crew
but I have no idea how to yeah well I
don't know if you have it installed oh I
don't know what to do what do I do
I just file open you have to hunt it
down but file open the file all Acrobat
I don't know where that file is how do i
how do I find the partner I know know
you're in Acrobat you need to open the
PDF no I understand that but Steven on
the preview window where there's at the
top of the menu it says test that PDF
and there's a little icon next to it you
know drag that onto your Adobe Acrobat
icon in your dock
oh boy well shoot what the heck have we
reported this bug to Apple um I don't
think so maybe we should yeah maybe we
should and you know I mean there may be
something that we can do but but you
know preview is gonna be something of a
black box to us so it's it may be the
reporting the bug to apples the best
there might be a workaround in in the
bug report if you look if it's that Lynx
even in the zoomed bug 2 - 6 0 2 - yeah
Tom there's apparently something called
interpolate true that this in the PDF
and if you change it it might actually
fix the issues that I scroll down a
little bit keep going keep going
there there hoops just up it's just a
little bit fixes the issue ok Tom show
like this just disagrees is a preview
bug in the sense that in the sense that
I think he thinks that because we have
interpolate true you know actually
interpolation actually though we in
current versions we don't have interplay
true we have interpolate false okay so
this here is an interpolate false case
where is the interpolated is it in the
it's separate folder there you go okay
so that's that statement okay he thinks
that the preview app ignores the into
the interpolation switching off
interpolation yeah
I would guess that's what's going on
there's nothing we can do if that's the
case I mean it's not our bug I mean what
we should do however how do we document
something like this do we put it in a
mean of course it's not true that
there's nothing we could do there is
something we could do it what we could
do is make the PDF
you know horribly large and inefficient
yeah but that's crazy I mean listen
great this is an issue because I've been
doing cellular automata a long time and
this this issue has come up multiple
times before it comes up in some what
does it come up in it
it comes up in PowerPoint I think as
well I mean obviously when PowerPoint is
resampling it's gonna cause trouble but
yeah you know and that may be what's
going on here that this is attempting I
mean I don't know whether there's a
magnification at which now just looks
like garbage I mean it's terrible
well I think that we should do a better
job of documenting this at least um the
there a possible issue I think it's
under possible issues yeah and I think I
don't know whether we do that of whether
we talk about destinations for you know
bad behavior in destinations for
exported material but we should report
the staple and which place should have
done that years ago maybe we did who
knows
um if if we did we we would have put it
in the bug report then you see if it
well I can look okay all right okay fine
all right
should we go on let's look at I'm happy
to report that the chrome render does
the right thing as well okay well maybe
there's a setting in preview as anybody
looked for that um
which says don't do is this a
preferences for preview loss screen size
on screen equal size on printout doesn't
seem to change another thing PDF oh not
a lot of options there ya know okay well
I think this is for Apple not for us
okay onward let's go to the next item
here brian is suggesting pursuit of a
popular PDF viewers and find a common
subset is well supported by all the
problem is this is it this is how you do
this kind of bitmap is with an image
operator there ain't anything else to do
I mean you know we're kind of stuck
there um okay also also it's difficult
for us to I mean when you say you know
find a common subset that's supported by
all you know that would mean we'd have
to dig deep into Cairo and change how
Cairo is doing things or we have to
fundamentally change how we draw stuff
you know if it were important we'd be
willing to do so but you know well
important is the wrong word if you know
if it were really valuable for us to do
we would do so but not automata book in
the preview app but it's you know
clearly there's a but but in this case I
think the only way to get it to work is
to draw rectangles and yeah well I think
the it almost makes me bring up a story
when the nks book was being printed
there was a it was done with director
plate printing where it went straight
from PostScript to actual plate drawing
on printing plates and it was over it
was over a holiday weekend and in 2002
that this was done and there was one of
these graphics that looked like this and
one side of it had a little glitch it
was a symmetric pattern on one side that
has a little tiny glitch and that glitch
so I I was trying very hard over that
weekend to figure out what the heck is
going on and so I contacted eventually I
guess John Warnock one of the founders
of Adobe and creator of PostScript and I
contacted him and I contacted the person
who was responsible for the director
plate printing renderer and each of them
said oh it must be our bug turned out it
was a bug in PostScript that had been
there for more than a day
cade um and had not been because people
were not used to seeing um if I can pull
it up this is irrelevant but we're since
we're since we're talking about bugs I'm
led to think about bugs here let me see
where is it
um yeah maybe here it looks like the
wrong place but anyway I have a system
so search know that doesn't seem
relevant that seems like the wrong thing
okay well I thought it was some um did I
mail it I didn't have it in here
i reaiiy didn't have it in the Sun in
the scrapbook I thought it was certain
here um ah anyway the UM
um oh yeah it isn't here it isn't I
thought it was in here there we go that
was the thing look at that little glitch
so on the other side there is no glitch
you see that there's a little Wiggy
thing there and there's nothing on the
other side that is a bug and PostScript
amusing um so you know and that by the
way is a bug in the image operator as
well
it's a bug in and some kind of
compression algorithm for the image
operator anyway it hits some to to the
end boundary or something I don't know
I'm not sure I know I I'm not sure I
know what the bug I probably didn't know
what the bug was um but anyway um okay
let's move on here graph bugs
okay are we gonna look at which one
should we look at here should we look
good probably this sir you couldn't we
can look at that one at six
okay what's the specific issue I think
there's not a single specific issue I
think there's I think Sowell's is on the
chat so he should probably say what he
specifically wants to know this is that
wealth Oriole I mean the question is
really what's happened to I mean you
know do we have an uncommonly large
number of bugs in the graph
functionality and if so where are they
and what's happening to them maybe
Charles can speak to that let me just
say first that you did tone down
development for a little bit on graphs
and networks in order to get capacity to
build out other areas however you know
we've been flowing capacity back on
there's a large number of bugs fixed
fundamental ones I mean some of it is
polished things you know steady flow but
some of the things we were aware of when
we designed it we didn't know how
important the area was to build out so
one example that came with 12 was
inheritance of properties for instance
one that's coming in 12 one which is
also at this sort of design level rather
than some something glitchyness was to
be able to address multigraph edges it's
gonna be something called tag graphs and
that's coming in 12:1 but short Charles
please look at that I even have a little
graph on the side of my screen there is
not per se a large amount of issue in
life I mean there have been some
specific bog users complaining about and
we have been trying to fix them every
release if you look at the post actually
did reply to the first and actually give
numbers or such so well there are issues
like in your area we are just trying to
fix them okay so to us is saying
multigraphs with properties what what's
the issue there yeah so
that's what's coming in 12:1 so you
could know that before but the problem
was what what is it what does it even
mean if if you really busy graph with me
- edge 1 goes to 2 1 goes to 2 right you
want to stand one red or the one you
know blue essentially I say I need to be
able to address them how are we doing it
in this one here I mean this is just
some random graph that those are
directed those are directed is not a
multi graph I see I mean it's not
something I mean we are aware of it
since we actually release graph that you
see a whole lot of implementation our
santa as what you point out is something
which will come in 12:1 if I say graph
of like table 1 goes to 1 goes to 2 you
know five times or something you're
saying okay and now the question is how
do you style each of those separately
right and if I just say or have any
property on them I can't I can't do that
that this doesn't work is that true
so which is obviously normal I mean 1
goes to 2 to all is the same object
right implicitly yeah I understand so I
understand so that this has to have some
shadowgraph inside where those edges are
somehow distinguished yeah yes we tagged
it will be a tag on those so you need
you need a racing name them
it's a tagged edge that is not just that
label by its endpoints that's right so
you need that unique identifier for the
edge
okay well so anyway so you've solved
this for 12 one is that true yes great
okay
by the way Karl on livestream is putting
out the Firefox also has the the its PDF
reader has the same issue well I think
that's a great thing to have in the
possible issue section um I mean I
wonder whether we should even have
something different I don't know whether
we've ever had this kind of
documentation before of
incompatibilities with external systems
in the case of Firefox what we could
conceivably go out and fix it for them
well we should look at that we should
least start a dialogue with them just
say you know point out this is wrong see
what they say all right so that's that's
a good that's a good action item thanks
guys all right so should we go on here
visualization is use 2d plotting panning
and zooming large datasets be a nice
feature it's gonna be a bit of work well
the issue is automatic I mean you know
auto panning and zooming we actually
have some capabilities in that direction
right and we have this notion of dynamic
graphics and so on yes we have dynamic
Geographics and we've discussed dynamic
graphics right so I mean if we do
dynamic Geographics then we could say of
wherever I don't know dynamic
Geographics of the eiffel tower so kind
of work so what it does it will give you
a street map around Paris okay so now
I'm let's go in boy this is not so I
guess we got a new geoserver coming next
week right hopefully is gonna make this
faster okay so that's panel and so on so
the issue is doing the same thing for a
for graphics objects
right well I mean technically it's not
for graphics objects is for the output
of specific visualization functions yeah
well why isn't it for graphics objects I
mean there could be a graphics object
because you know you you need something
that stores what you're which are
visualizing you know it like if it's a
plot you know what the function is so
that it can keep computing you know as
you as you zoom in or scroll around or
zoom out or whatever alright but
wouldn't it be cool if this could have a
satellite view based on dynamic geo
image I mean there is it do we have we
don't have dynamic to image do we or do
we we do not have dynamic geo image but
and we don't have an interactive toggle
but if you said geo background goes to
satellites or was a Geo server goes to
digital globe or whatever
what were those two things at the bottom
yeah what version of my running I have
no idea what version I'm running yeah
what is that
link to documentation for geo background
oh that's 12 one this is a 12 one
feature yeah cool why doesn't that have
an eye thing why is that a bookie from
because that's what we had the last time
we met about it so I personally think an
eye would be a better metaphor given
that that's what you see in the in the
hover you know in the raft that's cool
though I personally also think that that
should be it given that it's in a
different font you could put the eye on
the right hand side okay enough enough
for that but we should gum okay so just
I'm just curious where this works oh
well look at that that's cool so every
time it has to go back to the tile
server right and why isn't it working on
typing plus and it's not doing anything
I don't know actually it's posturing -
oh maybe we're only doing that for some
tiles
it's possible that the you may have hit
the limit of the satellite resolution no
I haven't hit the limit of the Geo image
satellite revolute resolution but I
think what's happened and that should
probably generate a message is that I've
hit the limit of what we're prepared to
give you without some because the
problem is that the Giro image you know
we're having to retrieve this from an
external provider right so here you
would have to activate your server goes
to dieter globe goes to what did you die
globe I see but I mean this is but I see
so you have to affirmatively my god
that's kind of weird
umm right so the activation is automatic
in your image but not in Geographics and
dynamic geographies okay fair enough but
okay so so backing up to the very large
number of points we agree this is the
thing we should be doing um and I don't
know whether there's much else to say
about it um yeah I mean it's it's that
the we should prioritize this this is an
important thing to do and I mean I guess
that's Bret is that for you or is that
for what where does that get done I
think they're two separate things I
think that dynamic I think that that
having better and more methods that deal
wid effectively data decimation or
compression if you like what we have
plot point max plot but it's not it's
not sufficient that's what I'm saying
it's not a sufficient kind of method
okay so the issue is the auto decimation
so to speak as you render the thing so
you're storing the data and we don't
seem to have a problem I mean that that
two issues one is is the data stored
locally or is the data stored in a file
and the other is how do we decimate it
when we actually paint it to the screen
that correct I think that the
the actual sort of this processing
pipeline needs to have more big data
oriented decimation algorithms so I
don't know how well you know max plot
points is going to respect whatever the
current plot ranges or if it's going to
sort of do it globally and then apply
the plot range as opposed to well that's
something you should look at I mean that
seems like a very that seems like a very
good thing to consider I mean then the
other issue is interactive zoom you know
zooming and panning so I think that's a
bit different okay you know if you want
this one thing if you view it as just
graphics into a hand and I think John
says correctly that's not what you
probably want is output from a plot
function I think that we want the
different plot container that allows you
to be active lead doing things so I mean
I I wrote a toy version of one of these
John your toy version is actually you
know folded into the actual actual
implementation for dynamic Geographics
okay so that that's a bigger change
what's what I'm saying the data
decimation and handling Big Data yes
it's it's a bunch of projects but I
think that those are more urgent to be
honest because people are hitting it now
and it should just it shouldn't grind to
a halt for that well but this question
about panning and zooming of plots
okay then two different issues one is
you've got the points there right there
the other is like a plot and you're
panning it you know along the plots and
you want to recompute the function those
are two different cases exactly I'm not
sure that they necessarily are two
different cases you know because they
are they behave similarly if you have a
huge amounts of data and if you decimate
it to a certain level you didn't need to
go back to the data and redo it if you
want higher resolution it's it's not
unlike the
doing a visualization of a continuous
function in that way yeah exactly
well okay fair enough but but it doesn't
require going back look in the graphics
object you have all the points but
that's a that's what you should my [ __ ]
wait no that's exactly what you
shouldn't do Stephen that's that's a
recipe for you're saying that even at
the level of lists plot it should
decimate before it is the graphics
object okay so then it is the same core
problem right so then we need a I mean
what we need is a general way to have
things like list plots make dynamic
output right but I think that that then
needs to be as I said there can't be
graphics itself it probably needs to be
a different container you know I
understand we're sorry you tell this
plot to make a dynamic output rather
than a static output I don't know we
haven't thought about that yet okay for
anything though there's you know two
possibilities that I see off the top of
my head right one is some sort of
wrapper and one is some sort of option
yeah I understand I think that's a
separate term that's a separate
discussion
yeah I think what what what I completely
agree with is is right away to get these
you know this is basically front line to
to to all the plot pipelines
that's it's what you deal with us did
you use simpler algorithms when you deal
with big data
we are very sophisticated geometric
pipeline for doing all these functions
we can tie on that that's you know just
it's right so okay I think we have a
part here and I agree it and let's let's
make sure that on the priority list
I mean these two items namely the the
pure decimation story and the dynamic
story which are two different stages but
they're both important right um
okay Ethan is complaining about several
things their local notebooks do not work
with remote kernels what why not
they've been doing that for 32 years
haven't they yeah I don't know why that
that's I don't know what it means by
that because I use it all the time it
might be a support issue govern you too
it's possible that there's some issue
but okay I mean does that mean remote
like on a different machine or I mean I
mean it's been like that it's worked I
thought for more than 30 years but what
can happen of course is that I mean
first of all there might be a glitch or
about but but second is that the
infrastructure gradually changes there
might be sort of another level of
authentication needed yeah I mean I've
ever translated and everybody started
using SSH as opposed to right earlier
that is there are no configuration
options are this is a very antiquated
system and this is in the process of
being being updated and there's our
kernel Connect kernel connection manager
is a global solution to this and I think
I mean John I don't know if you've
interacted with Roman yet about this but
he's in the process of not
comprehensively I mean I'm aware of the
project but it's not something we've
really dug into yet okay the second
complaint is that that our functions
aren't vetted to work on large-scale
data problems well that's a that's a
that's a good point that we were
partially discussing and arguably we
should have better testing of those
kinds of things
I mean it would be good to have specific
examples of problems so if even wants to
send a specific example they'll be very
helpful yeah we can always you know take
user cases are you we should obviously
do a better job but you know if there's
specific cases then we can you know
incorporate those in our test Suites to
make sure that you know those things run
fast and efficiently can I mention two
things for that audio has been out of
course since version since the first
version was released and that's one
thing that we have as a prototype in the
system that no matter how large is the
data we can handle it
the other thing is partial import/export
that I wanted to mention the CSV Excel
update that we did in version 12
supports a very efficient partial access
which is also gonna be a model for us
elsewhere for other formats to do very
efficient partial access do you
understand what partial asacs access is
if you don't pull in everything you pull
in what you need yeah right but I mean
we also had that big project to do
chunked uh access to external data so
you can have a giant out of core thing
and you know it's like a digestion by a
snake or something you're just looking
at small windows on that giant thing as
something that you pull into actual you
know to to core to compute that project
we temporarily suspended a couple of
years ago but I think that's going to
become active again
I mean in other words so that allows one
to have very large out of core data sets
I mean the idea was that that was a
thing if there is if there is a sort of
a standard quotes container if you like
a data arm that can then supply this
chunk taxes well that was the issue
because it's like what is it in is it in
a CSV file what is it yeah exactly I
mean I think that the yes and it's a
good point and I guess that you know one
can imagine processing it once to get it
into some standard container and then
going from there but I don't know what
would be the standard container I mean
there might be hdf file so there might
be something like that but it's not so
obvious to me at least that was one of
the things that that sort of had that
project halt um let's just go down this
list here
complaints about multi-threading and
parallel tools yeah I mean we have a
whole initiative around a compiler
project for dealing with that that's
just yes is that really the issue I
think they're talking about the parallel
tools you know
well we have parallel tools but that's
process based right I think Ethan is
asking about running multiple evaluation
threads I suppose in the kernel or right
and that's something that the compiler
will enable but but that's you know in a
50 million line codebase that's not an
easy thing to just switch on obviously
there are individual pieces like
libraries that do that but the you know
the whole system isn't going to do that
it's not even clear what it would mean
to do that um but you know as we as we I
think that there is room for a better
top-level language designed to do
concurrent programming though I well
that's interesting thing to think about
i I don't um but you're right there are
many subsystems like the graph subsystem
since we talked about that is largely
paralyzed across the board well so let
me comment another thing which is that
something that I guess will be rolling
out very soon is the ability to spin up
lots of for example AWS or as your
instances from within you know well from
desktop or within Mathematica um and
basically be able to say okay I want to
use a thousand kernels right now and we
are with we've just we're just finishing
the infrastructure for doing that I
think other other is that yet available
in private clouds
does anybody know we finished the HPC
version there's a sort of an HPC variant
of private clouds that allows that kind
of thing and there's also the idea of
doing that directly with AWS we have we
have been using internally for several
years an AWS link that allows you to do
stuff like that um and we are packaging
it we have a project I guess as soon as
Jesse finishes a different project he's
gonna be working on that project um to
basically have smoothly it be smoothly
possible you know if you pay for a
thousand cause you can spin that up and
start doing things and I think once we
have that we will sort of have an easy
test bed
to understand what actually makes sense
in terms of more you know parallel
programming types of tools but the more
fine-grained stuff that's that has to
wait for the compiler next complaint is
about the Wolfram cloud app what's wrong
with the Wolfram cloud app claiming it
gets 2 out of 5 stars
what's wrong with it Wow where are you
looking so even though cuz you don't
seem to scroll um I'm looking at them is
this an honor twitch chat oh and it's
also on yeah the twitch has a chat and I
copied and pasted Ethan blackhat 10
issues his top 10 complaints artist okay
we're addressing those um I'm trying to
so I mean this is a complaint about some
see whether I can bring this up so I can
bring up my old camera here and well
that's the cloud app now I mean I was
just doing this you know there's the
question is what is the optimal way to
like do typing and things in in the
cloud app I guess that's the question I
mean I think um you know if I start
going here and put cell that's what
happens if I do si and yeah it offers me
like cinch here I can do that okay
template well why doesn't it wait a
minute what did it just do did you see
what it just did
it did not replace that did you see what
it did yeah but I mean there's a
question of what the optimal UX for this
actually is and that's not a I mean that
is far from an obvious you know the
answer that is far from obvious to me at
least
um and in fact I mean we have an active
project to try and explore the UX for
you know for programming on a phone and
think there will be some improvements
there but we'd love to get suggestions
the next complaint from Ethan for you
John is frame rates in the desktop
front-end have massively degraded the
claim is can you come I mean that that
seems surprising to me I mean we just
did a giant rebuild to get 64-bit
capabilities on the Mac for example that
that is all new rendering code isn't it
well it's it's not new rendering code
but we I mean we do have we do have some
new rendering efforts that are coming
but it's a little unclear if he's
talking about graphics or if he's
talking about you know just kind of
general how responsive is it to you know
typing or scrolling or something like
that the yeah it's I'm finding it a bit
difficult to respond because I don't
quite know what direction to go in you
know okay the question is are we using
the latest rendering I mean we're using
we're now 64-bit we're now modern you
know you don't we're getting more modern
the I mean so for example the 3d
rendering system on Mac OS is still
using OpenGL but we're working on a
metal renderer but that only affects 3d
though that doesn't offend other sorts
of things so I mean you know which way
is this question going is well so we
need a little bit more information that
but but um okay next complains about a
lack of code cell auto format oh well it
might be sorry we have with the redmine
system and they're the new open bugs
database which I think Ethan is in the
previous program not sure but it could
be you know we can have him report
specifics there as well I'm not sure
either what he means with the frame rate
here but this is but this is open bugs
right so this is primarily for the 12
pointone pre-release program which I
suspect a lot of viewers are currently
either in or they can be invited if they
you know send message to support and
we're experimenting with this system to
track pre-release issues and then that
would be so so far it's been a very nice
experience and I think did the users
like it because they can see what the
status is of their issues and it's you
know it's relatively easy for us to
process into our internal system so
we're gonna you know take the next step
for that's pretty soon so you know so if
Ethan has specific issues that he hasn't
already reported to support right we can
the next comment is about code fellows
so I was just gonna say I mean then
talking about that and of course one of
the critical issues and you I'm sure
remember the first meeting where we
start talking about the Steven is is
autoformat to what's you know it's we
need to you know I mean on a formatter
has to have a style guide that we have
some time talking about this yes and so
there is an active project here it's not
going to deliver in 12-1 but there is an
active project error okay the next item
item 7 lack of standard web server
compatibility I believe we literally
today looked at a great solution to that
does anybody have the current draft of
the Wolfram web engine documentation
that they could pull up somebody could
ask oh yes a bow for that
yes no can somebody ask I'm not sure
which document this would be don't see
this I was showing today and in the ECE
meeting it might be in these denote help
again better no no the the Wolfram web
engine for Python oh okay yeah I can do
that supposed to give me one second um
which by the way we expect to be able to
push to github soon like soon as in
hours two days right well III don't
think hours but days yes I did what I
believe will probably be my final review
for that project to get it on github so
can yeah sorry okay well the next
complaint is about lack of multi-touch
okay it's on the zoom check so actually
let's bring this up first and they'll
get go back to multi-touch okay well
from web engine for Python okay so this
is and tell us if this meets your needs
but this is only this is not quite final
documentation but this is something
where for things like so this is for
things like Django and a io HTTP this is
integrating all from engine directly
into a web server so this is part of a
larger project where we you know try to
provide these sort of you know basic
building components on you know open
source on github you know as a starting
point for you know building connections
from for example you know python AAA
a io HTTP to you know go from engine you
know connection
so I'm I'm pretty optimistic but that is
actually satisfying
Ethan's number seven um and again he
might have specifics but then you know
like if we know the specifics we can
help the building or we can you know um
okay
lack of multi-touch John okay
so once again I don't know exactly what
he's referring to I could imagine a
couple different things there's some
multi-touch gestures on the Mac OS
trackpad that were not properly
supporting and we couldn't support them
before we move to 64-bit now that now
that we've done that they're there on
our development agenda and it would be
nice to have some multi-touch support
for trackpads and those sorts of devices
in our eventhandler system too if he's
talking not about trackpads but about
screens i don't know how common you know
multi-touch screens are in the desktop
laptop space certainly in the mobile
space they're quite common
obviously and we do have some
programming level support in the iOS
player for multi-touch screens but I
don't think that's really been I know we
break this down into two entities okay
one issue is sort of standard
multi-touch gestures and the other is
sort of programming level support in
event handler and so on I think first of
those is much more important and I mean
it's just like whatever happened to the
what is that thing called the touch the
thing that's on my macbook pro thing was
a cool touch bar or something what is
that called the little soft thing touch
for the little screen is talk oh yeah
right I mean that thing is kind of cool
in the cases where I use it um and I
know we couldn't support that before you
had 64-bit but now we can support it
does anybody care I don't know I mean I
when I got my
book pro i aggressively turned it off
because it kept it kept triggering what
I didn't want it to why do you care that
it triggers I mean so you don't because
because every time I'd hit the backspace
key Siri would come up and ask me what I
wanted why because the Siri button was
right above the backspace key oh well
that's that's okay
oh and so I had to make sure that
portion of the touch bar didn't have
anything on it because I was
accidentally pressing it all the time
okay well I I managed to get my fingers
to go in the right places enough I guess
but I mean to me it's a little weird
that you know if somebody was looking
over your shoulder you typing you know
email even if they can't see your screen
they can see all kinds of weird
completion suggestions and the touch bar
which is a little odd but but you know
not not really my issue but still I you
know I think it's nice it's like a
predictive interface you know it's it's
it has a well no I mean it we could use
it to put up things that come from our
particular interface for example yeah
but but a practical example is you know
one might suggest that pinch zoom ought
to change our mind of kish levels and in
a notebook yes and in the 32-bit version
their Apple just didn't give us the
tools to do that you know we can do it
now we just haven't done it because it's
you know in this queue of things that
having a 64-bit version now enables okay
are we nice to know what the list of
gestures that we think we care about
isn't be able to prioritize them and
maybe people can suggest if if if people
use us here have suggestions about that
we'd like to hear them all right next
item from Ethan lack of modern UI
components like tabs dark mode
drag-and-drop fading scroll bars so I
would maybe disputes that a little bit
on the drag and drop points
the I mean we do support drag and drop
of files and drag and drop of other
sorts of things is you know it's I mean
there's it can get into a bit of
dangerous territory there I mean let's
be realistic ten years ago we had
design with drag receivers and all this
kind of stuff yes and I use that design
and anger and that's why it never went
any further because I realized all the
shortcomings of that design and couldn't
figure out a way around them but I think
drag-and-drop is hard to integrate into
an existing I mean I think there's some
simple drag-and-drop which we do pretty
well yeah the important the really
important thing is to interact with you
know the file system or things coming
from other programs and I think we do
well we could do better but I think
we're doing well I think we don't better
than most other applications in terms of
dragging an image and things like that
and I think we're better at decoding you
know what the image is and things like
that
no now the other thing city lists you
know I totally stipulate tabs you know
is long past due there's some
interesting things we can do with scroll
bars the actually eye fading scroll bars
and maybe he might be referring to the
Mac OS without you know well that could
only be moved yes I think it's time I
think it might be time for a little bit
of a refresh
I don't but the and and also you know
we're looking you know at many Maps down
the road but and dark mode you know we
will get dark mode eventually but you
know dark mode is basically a tool by
you know companies with thousands of
developers and you know billions of
dollars who you know can make you know
us smaller guys have to work really hard
to do things to try to you know play
catch up with them I'm sure that some
people love dark mode and it does look
pretty but it's it's not it's not simple
it's kind of weird you know with plot
themes we have dark mode plot themes
since version 10 or something like that
yeah yeah you know doing you know kind
of one-off things and dark and and we
have you know we can do style sheets
that you know in general do dark but
it's it's like how do I get to go you
know it for for a product like ours that
dog color or something
you know but but for a part like an arse
where the the visual design is you know
kind of deeply you know thought-out and
woven through the system I think there's
a style sheet Stephens you can do Y is
plot theme dark whatever dark mode is
why isn't it available here it's right
here I think you need to I think it's
get automatically invoked when you have
a dark stripe style sheets so if you do
a style notebook open style notebook oh
well there's go style no no go to style
notebook file open new new okay and you
do the style notebook and pick a dark
one like that one reverse color for
instance and now we just do a plot and
it should automatically be in dark mode
wow I've never even seen that red thing
is that really what we want
that's totally missing a bracket oh well
that's why it's red but I mean that
isn't that totally funky that's
apparently the alternate color for the
green highlighting yeah is it the right
thing I mean is it really right why do I
want to evaluate initialization cells do
I need to do that no no no it's just
just simple content there's a code cell
in there somewhere at the bottom the
axis are bright you know the X is a
white big deal no I mean do try anything
I mean it has to work across the board
that is so weird that that's red nobody
needs to okay well that's nice I mean I
think that's a rather dark if I might
say so that blue is not the most
beautiful blue forgiving that this is
supposed to be dark yeah I don't know if
it's doing personally I think this
reverse color thing the stylesheet could
do a little bit of work maybe what you
wanted you want it you know it's
never-ending
yeah people care about this I mean that
that's a well fair number of bug reports
you know about you know such-and-such
style or such-and-such element you know
so we've had this sort of thing since
before dark motor school and there were
you know there were some people who were
interested in and especially especially
people who have you know vision yeah low
vision eye that's a case that's a case
where I can see a real use for this but
you know now that it's built in to
operating systems it's getting a lot
more attention and you know every
operating system wants us to do it their
way and it's you know it's like taking a
lot of our design and having to kind of
you know not start over from scratch but
he'll he do a lot of effort to figure
out how to integrate with operating
systems I mean to me it's ironic because
this looks pretty much like what
terminals look like in the 1970s I mean
it's just kind of weird that now it's
retro cool again like this is this is
not a dark theme right this is our style
sheet that happens to be right would be
if if if if somebody has dark mode set
in their OS should our new notebook
default to a dark mode new notebook well
actually I think I think that's not
really the right way to think about it
because the here's the thing that's
going to really make you think is but
what about all the existing notebooks
you know to somebody else or you send it
to somebody else yeah one might say is a
personal preference that should not be
written into the notebook but then you
have to have alternate styles
well that's similar if I might say so to
you know the published dialog that we
now have says do you want to preserve
the magnification or not when you
publish the notebook and the default is
not to preserve the magnification so
similarly you could imagine you know
preserve the dark mode setting or don't
yeah you're not gonna prompt people
every time you save a notebook cell no
not every time you say but in the case
of the published dialog I mean in the
case of saving we are
preserving the magnification right but
in the case of publishing to the cloud
it's offering you the opportunity to not
save the magnification and by default is
not saving magnification so similarly I
mean look I honestly I think is one of
these things as you say where if you
have you know absolutely excess software
engineering capacity you could do this
it's not clear that it's a high priority
maybe and I'm certainly not saying that
that we won't or shouldn't do it but
it's you know we have a lot of things in
our queue and you know we will and you
know we have to look at our mobile apps
for for dark mode as well which is
probably a bit of a higher priority
because the you know the the want on the
mobile side is is maybe more desperate
so yes I mean I think I was looking for
something here um that might be
interesting to see in terms of drag and
drop we've been experimenting with pure
drag and drop versions of um um let's
see here's one pure drag and drop
versions of the language um actually
this is not the best version probably
but if I do um you know what this is
what am I doing here
help
well that's clearly not the right thing
um anyway just you know as a complete
interface that has drag and drop that is
based on drag and drop um it has kind of
the discovery and face from blocks
there's actually a slightly a more
recent version of this that exists um I
don't even know whether we can let's see
what happens if I say but but but uh
what do I can I do with numbers um how
can I do here if I say sign click well
it's a exponential of wants to make it a
little bit smaller 66.7 ah let me do
that what is it doing it's not letting
me it's not letting me edit this because
which you placed I think was an integer
oh no I think it was it or was it a
number okay I think so I know I first
run that uh
what the heck okay okay but this is not
very smooth yet but that's kind of an
idea for a complete drag-and-drop
interface but I think our efforts to
kind of merge a drag-and-drop interface
into an existing Notebook environment
have what were at least as of ten years
ago and we did quite a bit of work on
that design really didn't make it um
yeah okay let's look at IIIi built a
keyboard designer with that design you
may recall seeing that some years ago
and remember that yeah it was I would
not have asked our users to have done
what I had to do to make that work so
well you built something for designing
keyboards for our mobile apps right that
that involves drag-and-drop yes that's
actually an interesting example maybe we
should put that in the function
repository if anybody wants to design a
keyboard it's an interesting example
could we do that
or I could check to see if it still
works
fine I thought we ripped out the
drag-and-drop code no it's I we didn't
rip it out but we certainly never
documented it all right well anyway
let's see if it works would be fun to
see that just as an example of what can
be done there so the next complaint here
is lack of external code cell syntax
highlighter we are very well aware of
that
John you in fact think you have a
solution to that I misinterpreted what
he was asking so I'm assuming whether he
was talking about in external editors or
I think this is like external so yeah I
think it's like Python highlighting like
you know there's okay on the web there's
toolkits like pigments for example where
you know there's support for all sorts
of languages and since we have Python
yeah some I have some thoughts about how
to deal with that but you were telling
me last year right what I'm thought was
it as I was working what is this
is that because it has some weird
complaint about what is it doing here
oh that's weird you must listen sir it's
summer and I inserted a new line but it
wasn't displaying the new line yeah you
may have some Alt key or something
that's something but by the way this is
going to be a much longer list real soon
right
four twelve one that's gonna be much
longer list yeah we hope so yes there
okay let's keep going we've got quite a
lot of other comments or well we got a
lot of other comments on the on the live
stream here let's let's look at a few of
these um let's see okay regarding big
datasets or isn't the discussion about
iterators yes we are going to talk about
that um we haven't we haven't that
probably coming to will probably live
stream the discussion of that as part of
our incremental language development
discussion I have to admit I haven't yet
read that giant there's a giant internal
thread about that I mean this is
something that's come up again
it comes up every few years gosh we had
I had an iterate function back in SMP
which I happened to look at again
recently back in 1979 1980 had a general
notion of iterators but we never yeah it
to be looked at um
import/export dump image read PNG it is
all magnitude faster than the documented
import and that's familiar that he's
saying that there's some internal
function image backtick input export
done backtick imagery PNG sounds orders
might read faster than the documented
imported PNG which is used in sorry
sorry you sound like you're in a cave is
this better not much actually but we can
hear you what that at context function
imagery PNG is used in important
we know important exported have some has
some overhead and it is planned to look
at it and see if we can improve on that
but orders of magnitude doesn't sound
like import-export framework overhead
that sounds like some other issue
depends on the size of the file fines
it's a very large number of tiny pngs
that might hang there okay I know that
you're planning to do a framework update
there yep okay a comment from Peru
Vaughn you can also use CUDA for
multi-threading yeah I mean our CUDA
support is a bit old and we're looking
together with with some outside
partnerships to I know you I think you
have a very okay um
the to upgrade that yeah I just want to
say one thing about multi-threading that
a lot of multi-threading happens but it
happens completely you know unbeknownst
to the user like all our you know mkl
library functions and probably image
processing functions they are
multi-threaded but you know and that's
why they're you know so fast so but it's
not visible I think that looks and so on
is all multi-threaded right it's just
that user level control of
multi-threading is not a fine-grained
user level control isn't there really
won't do seriously supportable until we
have the compiler right um but till we
have the GNU Compiler okay comments
about iterators and generators yeah okay
well good thank you that that's good
encouragement we will be talking about
those soon um adding a deployment option
to deliver Mathematica apps for docker
containers would be huge okay
interesting um this has to do with
standalone I assume this has to do with
standalone applications and the ability
to have a complete wolfram engine in the
application as a docker container so
maybe uh node can we can you comment on
that you can do that I I have something
on on the docker hub
I'm gonna need a few seconds to find
that but it's in I know it's personal
account right now but on our to-do list
is to have an official wolfram accounts
so let me understand what that is so
from wolfram script you can start things
with a standalone you know with the
thumbs in some standalone front-end mode
put it on the zoom chance so you know
we're working with that and there might
be other people in the company working
on you know similar things but you know
like you you can you know take the free
wolfram engine for developers you know
or whatever and you can you know write a
simple darker script and you know you
could have that duck rice and I think
what he's asking is like you know this
would be the base case and then plus
your own application like whatever you
know application you have and add it in
there or if you have like a server
application you would do that but you
know like anything and then you know
push that to the docker hub so you you
know people can use it I mean the
licensing is the trickiest part so
that's you know the the thing we really
want to think we have that nailed for
the free water manager to developers or
not the licensing side of this it's I
have instructions in here how to do it
so yeah I mean it's you have to have
instructions is always a bad sign
yeah okay fair enough so that's so
that's a remaining issue there but it
sounds like this is on the way now I
think you know this question about
packaging a standalone application
that's something that we have worked on
for wolfram script right I mean we've
got some where is the I need to pull up
the Wolfram script home page um which by
the way I hope there's a link to that
from the why is this typing slowly is
this maybe I'm running 12-1 here
it will be good for this page to link to
does this page link to no it doesn't
that's crazy crazy that should link to
the essentially marketing page for
Wolfram script that makes sense on ode
you know it looks like a bug too because
if if that's empty the related links
that you have been stripped down but is
there nothing under URL there let go to
URL no that's a different thing that's
the URL of this page
oh no that's the oral don't go to web
URL what it's supposed to do it goes to
the web version of this yeah that's not
the that's not the actual thing that
explains well from script that's just a
bug we should fix that and this is
presumably the 12-1 documentation which
isn't finished yet but the whole point
is that there is this thing for making a
standalone application where you're just
launching from the wls file correct
where it starts with a hash bang Wolfram
script right
yeah well that already works right of me
there's Wolfram language scripts WLS
fast what doesn't work is the pulling up
a standalone notebook interface is that
correct
right there that doesn't work that's not
finished yet but although that was in
motion at some point it was but it's
less in motion now is it still on the
list it's on the list here but it's you
know it's gonna it's been somewhat down
prioritized so be interesting to know
from people if they if they're
particularly interested in that that's
the ability to have not just a Wolfram
engine Wolfram script you know
essentially command-line interface from
a for example within the docker
container but something which could
actually bring up a notebook interface
from within the docker container right
for example yeah so then Ethan goes on
to say iOS and then for iPad and iPhone
I wonder if even is aware of our player
for iOS
[Music]
I'm sorry um let's see okay we got a lot
of comments here and we're going to run
out of time soon um hold on well yeah
that's another important thing to say is
delivering apps delivering notebook
based apps through the the player on iOS
so that's then a full wolfram engine
running on iOS with a with a notebook
interface right where you're delivering
probably do a demo of that let's see
[Music]
I think I'd see what I've got here but
Tim
how is it
[Music]
I don't know this is gonna work very
well I think I'm I'm um
yeah bunch of random
and files here um what's that that might
be something you could show no idea what
this is okay um but yeah that the full
thing is runnable here um but that
that's that's then running in the
notebook interface okay um let me see
where were we here Carl Lang is next
well from cloud app on androids um
caught up on Android is gonna pour okay
so that Wolfram cloud app on Android
well can can anybody count John can you
comment on that it's not with anything
particularly informative at this point I
mean it's not that that's I mean it's
actively being developed is it not it is
yeah yeah so if there's something wrong
with it
we'd like I mean do we already know
things that are wrong with it or would
we like to know more common it's it's
not as good as the iOS one it's
definitely meets work okay but I mean if
do we do we need comments about what
people think is important or do we
already know what we think is important
well I think it wouldn't hurt okay let's
see
tangled spaces saying no text copy and
paste I'm not sure quite what that's
referring to
is that on the Android app or you can
only copy place two whole cells in the
Android app unclear okay Ethan is saying
any long-running computations in the
cloud app fail image 3d and graph 3d
aren't interactive um why is graph 3d
not interactive and that should be a
graphic subject why is that not
interactive image 3d might be different
graph 3d involves all the dynamic stuff
I think in a way that is probably not
quite supported yet well I did some
specific case of graph not all of them
where we actually have more complex
computation require a leader position of
the image an image 3d shadi you can
public comment on that I mean that's
using quite different technology is that
true yes I mean image 3d is I mean
getting that to be performant on desktop
is occasionally interesting but shoddy
or
John can you comment on what is the what
is the underlying the underlying
technology of image 3d is not the same
as the underlying technology of graphics
3d correct just same as raster 3d
graphics trivial raster 3d no I
understand but raster 3d is its own
creat oh I see it's I see ok when are we
getting a ray plot 3d by the way yeah
I'm sorry you're breaking up Steve Wow
okay that's really that was a joke oh
because you were asking about a plot 3d
ok funny but what's the answer
but is it is it for your team it's
probably for my team and I mean I think
it's one of those things where it again
runs into you know that array plop bug
that we were looking at earlier we're
having something that robustly looks
discretized it's hard so it's so mighty
let's be clear that wasn't our bug
question oh no but I'm saying that you
run into a similar sort of thing with
you know raster 3d so I think there's
probably still some more work from you
to on the rendering side to be able to
have something that is you know crisp
and I mean if you have a hundred by a
hundred by a hundred it's going to be I
mean how different is it from re mesh
Ramesh returns I mean that's part of
what we need to look at I think if it
can't be done with that style of
technology that's in raster 3d which it
may be in which case that would be a win
no it's very simply look at that that's
again his life in 3d I mean that that's
pretty nice yeah so in terms of doing
this on the cloud I mean you know we're
working with a different set of
rendering technologies that are much
much impoverished compared to what's
available on the desktop and yes because
the WebGL renderer that the youth and
exactly it's not I mean that WebGL
renderer doesn't support everything it
really doesn't okay
I mean because this is it's difficult to
appreciate what's going on on the
desktop I mean this is you know
rendering this is not like we are
rendering polygons it's really a very
different kind of thing going on behind
the scenes
oh yeah it's cool though sorry I'm just
playing but um let's see I wonder what
happens if I do four hundred situps and
now it's gotten slow it's getting well
actually it's rotating a decent speed
why is there so much space around it
looks like a bug to me why is there so
much space why is it why is it
effectively gone to spherical region
true I don't know looks like a bug to me
if you delete the output and redo it
does it change I'm wondering if there
was a cached image size affecting it in
any way yeah oh no no now now that was
even more bizarre did you see what just
happened yeah I didn't that doesn't seem
promising to me but look at this I mean
this this is I've never really been able
to use these and make them work okay why
did that pink out why on earth did that
pink out alright right might be some on
there development books oh this is one
this is this is I'm running to a one
right in which case I'm impressed that
we haven't crashed your front end yet or
something right this is yesterday's bill
so I'm sorry I'm impressed we haven't
crashed your kernel yet okay all right
well okay so um let's see um more UI
components would be nice someone's
commenting um sorry I'm gonna have to
leave for commitment
okay well we'll keep going for a little
longer here but complaints about
comparing dynamics to d3 and so on um
[Music]
yeah I mean you know browsers have
signed up for less than we are
delivering and have spent
you know very large development
resources they also don't have to
develop the kernel but yes
okay autoformat checkout Patrick's
IntelliJ Wolfram language plugin it's
Auto formatting is great what is it
doing we thought of what is that what is
the Patrick plug-in doing for auto
formatting I'll try to pull up the link
and I know you can see some demos there
give me a second web engine looks great
that's good to hear
okay link is on this was funny about
Dell XPS surface etc all Windows laptops
support multi-touch with up to sensible
taneous touch points yeah but I'm not
sure how much software actually you know
is savvy to that yeah how about is
complaining about the fact that the
Escape key went soft on a MacBook Pro I
know it's crazy there's a link on the
zoom chat if you want to took it look at
so there's some animations I'm not sure
if autoformat actually has an animation
but there's some examples of what is the
I mean oh and what are his styling rules
do we know what do you mean with styling
rules look even that auto auto indent
which we don't seem to have for code
sells that's crazy that we don't have
that yeah I think that's just a feature
of that editor that you know every
finger should we should do sure we
should look at that um we really should
look at that I mean that's a simple
change to just make some basic you know
things like auto indent work um okay
hold on
multi-touch depends you know hardware I
think pixel book is one of the best okay
addictive keylogger not sure that means
I meant dragon drop only within notebook
season clarifies okay for UI components
well show us some examples what that
really would be useful because as I say
we did a pretty big effort of design on
this ten years ago um we didn't find it
useful um okay so it says until couple
weeks ago I didn't even know that one
can option drag on that file paths to
notebooks you know what I'm not sure I
know that I know well so I have two
comments about that first is that it is
actually a system standard although it's
you know one of those system standards
that isn't very well known but you know
it works in lots of apps and the second
is that what are you saying you're
saying if I option drag this thing yeah
nothing happened my option or option
drag option oh but the heck just
happened here help
what is arm well let me do it to a non
non non preliminary version here non
prototype version so you're saying
option drag of the what is it doing it
looks down option after you select the
after you start dragging I think it
might be changing window focus and then
option and now I let it down what do you
know yeah I didn't know that work so
that's a standard thing across lots of
applications but Ian and I were
discussing what we could do to try to
make things more parents but I know the
I doubt that's even documented in in any
I mean there are some guide pages that
have documentation about those kinds of
things yeah I mean but you know like
like an equivalent thing under you know
is like under Windows using you know
control f6
cycle between your document windows you
know that's it's another example of
something that works in like almost
every app but lots of people don't know
that okay I just have to remember this
option drag because I you know it's
super useful well I mean it's only been
there since version 5 or something I
mean when was that
well maybe not five but five point two
for sure somehow something like that
more than ten years okay well okay um
all those styles are kind of ugly Ethan
is saying I think he's referring to the
dogstars we were looking at earlier um
ah ok Gustavo is saying the reverse
color stylesheet is broken for some data
set displays and transfer function
objects that's not a hundred percent
surprising I'm hoping to make some
infrastructural changes that'll make
that less likely to be you know easier
for internal folks to properly deal with
things I look don't complain about that
the one with headers yeah go open the
data set and copy data dataset Doc's
like anything like that like ya know
suspected that's just gonna not be okay
okay I mean it's not fantastic but it I
don't think one should complain
vociferously about that um okay so there
may be some other issue here I wouldn't
be surprised that there's another issue
and transfer function objects see what
we're looking for transfer what is it
called transfer function model
this could be bad I admit that this this
is this could be bad and okay well so
that's a that's a question I mean that's
something that we should have automated
tools to look at at a QA level for
making sure that these Styles have you
know let through enough of the light -
so to speak
do not go wrong right I mean that's it
that's an absolute style of some kind
but you get what I'm saying arnoud yeah
i'm you're saying i'm not sure how to do
that like off the top of my head so i
maybe john has an idea how to do it but
that okay that's a bug thank you I mean
we're a she's here so I'm sure you'll
take a notes in yeah we can fix
particular cases but I I can't think off
the out of my automatic way to find such
Styles all over the place well I think
you look at the boxes and you ask the
question I mean there's some aspect of
these boxes maybe John can comment or I
think he and I I mean I have some proto
ideas okay um in Reverse color code
cells are unreadable oh shoot okay let's
look at that that was a that was a
command line command dead track mandates
yeah not great
what about external evaluate cells are
they okay I mean they could be they
could be different I mean we could make
this look even more kind of what can I
say retro
yeah even more dark and retro um I don't
think these are great but they're not
they're not shocking um
okay for dog mode probably something
that's needed ISM some dynamic color
palette I list of colors that change
dynamically according to whether you're
in doubt whether or not yeah yeah and I
kind of implied that earlier I think
he's not wrong I think this is part of
the essential difficulty of getting a
good dark mode implementation
okay Carlos is upset that godmode isn't
a high priority because he thinks
professional programmers prefer dark
mode Wow
I mean it's like crazy it's it's like I
remember when people were like seeing
the early Xerox Altos and you know and
the early bitmap displays and then the
Sun workstation it was like people were
thrilled it's black on white that's
that's fantastic and now I mean how
people has there been a set of people in
the world who have used you know white
on black forever since the 1980s or has
it been that it's gone and come back
again
well yeah it's I mean I think it's
difficult to answer that question yeah I
think that prevailing styles in I des is
that it's a darker theme that's actually
not really true there are many popular
IDs on you know I mean like Xcode Visual
Studio you know these have been you know
using the light colors for years and
years right add some and sublime and
intelligent yeah but that's a relatively
new Jo that's like in last 10 years and
all of those you know you know they have
a default theme but they leave open
support for multiple themes as well well
it's interesting people here really
caring about dogmas that's really useful
for us to see and this thing about
dynamic color palettes yes absolutely
that would be what would have to happen
I mean that's it that's a framework
change that it's not inconceivable right
I mean it you know it's a question of
interacting through some color table
that we're not doing right now I think
that's worth us at least talking about
Brett is whether there's a way to have a
symbolic reference to a color I mean
like the answer I mean in certainly in
some style context we're already playing
with that you know it's not widely
deployed yet but you know we have
of you know we have some you know some
implementations to do that right now
I mean if you do the file new presenter
notebook is exposing some implementation
or something like that
I think vs code is also the theme colors
there you know so that's that's
basically you know there are references
throughout these style sheets of you
know that basically say like color one
color to color three which are then
pulled from whatever you chose your
theme colors to be yeah that's nice we
just need to make sure that any time
somebody constructs a new object that
they are you know appropriately choosing
from identified styles yeah yeah so
obviously that just deals with the style
problem it doesn't deal with the with
the Brett problems of visualization
functions and such but it's a start and
something to build on I think I tried to
type hello wow I thought oh it's
automatically going to all caps that's
really weird
oh it's yes that's actually that's the
style of that of that particular style
sheet which I'm not a fan of but but I
guess the designers liked it no this
doesn't make any sense
this doesn't make any sense this is a
second level heading it's more it's
bigger that's crazy
complaint and that's pretty crazy too
this is a crazy this is crazy what's
happening here now I admit that I
changed from the default colors but
that's crazy the fact that a command one
right is smaller than a command to camp
can we report that please Raj that's for
you if
um okay let's see
please don't make dark moments doc just
because the OS is set to top mode fine
um it's very hard to create a graphics
color scheme that works well both in
dark and light mode my graphics will
eventually end up as PDFs viewed or
printed by collaborators I need reliable
it's inconsistency in a light background
yeah fair enough
um okay um okay from Ethan creating a
Mac desktop app will be awesome if we
could hook our Xcode project into
Mathematica or into okay so what does
that mean so that means accessing the
Wolfram engine from within Xcode is that
what we're talking about so we actually
have something that looks a lot like
that in terms of what we're currently
calling CDF kit but what for iOS and one
could imagine a similar sort of
interface for the desktop platforms to
where it's basically you know all of all
of the wolf management stuff is
available as a Mac OS framework that you
can then call from objective-c or Swift
so hold on hold on what one thing would
be to call from engine from within you
know through like just like we have the
language client library for Python we
can have it for Swift or Objective C or
whatever and then the Wolfram engine
could be part of a cobia component built
into an Xcode project yeah yeah and do
we have that or do we have we have a for
iOS okay but we haven't distributed that
have we we've distributed to a few
people it's it's a thing we've we calls
CDF KITT okay butBut that also supports
notebook capabilities yes
not just the engine that's right so
we could do that for the free wolf
invention for developers we could
support that in Xcode couldn't we I mean
I think we've certainly had it on the
roadmap to do it for a variety of IDs
and I think that's our node can you
speak to that yeah that's not at the top
of my list of priorities and well I'm
not sure how possible that is because
Xcode is what things have changed but at
least for a for a while
Xcode has been seriously locked out in
terms of what you can actually plug into
it the you know they used to have a
richer plug-in scheme and then they had
that you know they had that incident
where people were using you know some
kind of malware infested Xcode in China
and afterwards Apple you know really
lock things down hard and disabled a lot
of plug-in functionality that used to be
there so I'm not sure what's even
possible well we could talk to them
about that but but I mean in okay so
look first that first question is can
Wolfram engine be incorporated into
Xcode with an objective-c or Swift
interface first question second question
can a notebook capability be put into
Xcode I think both of those are worth
investigating and should be part of our
nodes or they actually it's part of the
ECE groups there's Xcode for the desktop
right in this Xcode for the iOS is that
right children well it's it's it's one
if there's only one Xcode but it has two
kinds of targets it can compile to write
and I think the iOS one is the more
exotic possibility because it would
allow you to build a custom app that's
the desktop one is also interesting yeah
I think so sounds like a client library
type situation where except that it
needs Xcode embedding right and that's
the non-trivial thing and John is saying
that there's an issue with whether
apples rules about what gets embedded in
Xcode you know
we have to go to a lot of effort to have
Apple approve whatever our packaging
well I mean and frankly you know the
underlying technology may not even exist
I mean when we did the web browser
plug-in you know the web browser plug-in
we had to do some really bizarre things
to get that to work well so fine I think
we should investigate this yeah um okay
let's continue here just looking at this
cause platform deployment solution okay
regarding the import interface for PNG
import because I'm anxious strolling
into a function it uses for the
following example it's 50 times slower
oh my gosh
I saw that example but still we're
looking at under a second increase and
that's the import-export framework
overhead okay fine so it's small it's
it's it's basically three that well
these are three thousand by three
thousand things and what that's telling
us is that the actual underlying import
is blindingly fast and all the times
being spent in the framework so okay
something to do um
rotation okay cursor placement control
is a problem in the Android app trying
to close place the cursor between
specific characters are we aware of that
problem the so I know that not just on
Android but on iOS we designed it so
such that it's easier to tap between
cells then inside of a cell and if you
have a cell that's not very tall then it
may be difficult to to do it by tapping
but there are arrow keys and the arrow
keys should work either on every on
every Android device there are Oh keys
oh no no no we we we add we added the
arrow keys as part of the controls that
come up yeah okay well that's question
um okay Ethan is saying export HTML is
more body than export to PDF but
exporting to markdown will be useful and
easier to implement well
we've been working on that anybody want
to talk about markdown export John I
think that I think that there was
somebody else who was working on that
project I remember who it was okay but I
think that has that is supposed to be an
active project I don't know whether
people you know who could speak to that
but I think I think there are some
external solutions for that as well I'll
put one on the chat here of course you
know a significant part of it is if
markdown is such an impoverished format
in many ways that you know you can you
know it might not be a really
complicated project if you're just happy
with low fidelity output yeah
well I think this is something we've
talked about I think we should do this
I think we should do this and I think we
should also do markdown import to
notebooks and so on that's something for
I guess that's for shadi yeah not the
export of it okay fair enough
but maybe the import of it this has been
honor
floating around on our list and I think
it really should get done ok style sheet
oh yeah
style sheet repository yup we've
absolutely talked about this it's
absolutely doable and it's in the
roadmap not super quickly but but we're
numbers about green on black ok ok
I don't Hawk Twitter
Jupiter is not thought by default I
think that's because they basically just
assumed that what we did in notebooks
was the right thing to do which might be
a bad assumption pink is saying I
changed our code regular depending on
the time of day and season boy these
these some you know how did everybody
survive without dark mode
damn it while we were in the dark ages
of flight mode um Wow okay I mean okay
this is great to see all this enthusiasm
for dark mode it's interesting I mean it
does look kind of nice I have to say um
Bob's I expect out no got popular
because of the Matrix films that's funny
it doesn't I mean even terminator has a
scene on an old-fashioned mainframe like
thing I don't think that was some okay
is it possible to use Wolfram language
in Visual Studio so what's what's the
thing to say about that I mean that the
on another so there's a plugin for vs
code I'm not sure about facial studio
but vs code is this sort of a separate
editor that Microsoft makes and yet we
good - we're good to have a definitive
answer that no not on our IDs competitor
the way we do we do like it's literally
on the page here let me let me share
that so yeah you know actually showed it
but I know it has this really nice
github repository of you know that he's
collected of all those sorts that that's
what this has turned into so oh that's
okay there it is okay yeah so if there's
other ones you know like we can add them
and we can link to it and now that's
that's not Visual Studio still
interesting yes I suspect that for now
the answer for Visual Studio proper is
no that's my suspicion but well the one
on the bottom left is pigments package
that that's the one that's you know
multi-language syntax colouring support
earlier and we're part of that there
there's a
somebody wrote they forget who he was
I should probably no that's okay anyway
Ethan is complaining the presenter
notebooks are very very slow and clunky
I hope that's been fixed in 12 oh they
were before 12 oh try it again
that a fair thing to say John yes I mean
I think they could still be faster but
there is definitely a major improvement
for eleven three to twelve and I'm
hoping there will be yet more
improvements from 12 to 12 1 okay so
okay so Cheryl wants to know about
making a document into a web viewable
form easily that cloud boy nobody that
I'm looking at okay so this is an
example he's offering I'm guessing this
the impressive growth package right
right so this is a PDF
okay so look I'll tell you something you
know I take these notebooks that I make
big notebooks and I say cloud publish
them and usually okay let's let's just
let's make a let's make a UUID for this
publish and the amazing thing is these
days this actually works and you can
take this one is it's particularly
complicated now the longer I wait the
more likely it is that there's going to
be an HTML cache that's already been
produced so a thousand one thousand and
two thousand and three and how long it
will take let's take a look here okay
here we go
okay so didn't finish producing the HTML
cache down there but isn't this pretty
cool but but like does this cost cloud
credits if other people look at this no
it does not
that's though you can publish this so
long as the people don't okay so there
we go so this is some why that's
spinning there that's
unfortunate but that's odd that that
would be spending that's that's worth
reporting as a bug okay Raj can you
report that please how many not okay
um in any case you know so this is the
notebook that I just created right I
wonder whether this gosh I wonder
whether this works my gosh that is
amazing I had no idea that would work
Wow isn't that pretty cool but that
works in a cloud notebook I'm impressed
right I mean it's a cloud specific
implementation so what I mean it works
yeah this is like 1.50 or 1.51 or
something I think it wasn't 1.51 which
just came out like two weeks ago or
something but anyway I mean okay so
everything was about specific limitation
for everything you look at is it but
this is the deployed view and I think
you know until recently this was not
realistic to do this but now can
somebody put in the chat the JavaScript
in better library
when the new if somebody can bring up
the the new publish dialog I don't know
whether that's excessive in the dia did
notebook and better thing yeah the
notebook can better um
let's bring that up and then then bring
up the if you happen to have the new I
just reviewed it like today or yesterday
or something the new cloud publishing
dialog from desktop so the notebook and
better is a link that I just put on the
zoom chat for you okay I don't think
anybody has seen that because it hasn't
been announced yet okay so this is a way
this is this is gonna be relevant this
you're gonna care about this is a way of
embedding a notebook seamlessly into a
web page
okay deployed notebook seamlessly into a
web page okay examples okay wow this is
cool dark mode huh yeah so it is what am
I seeing
it's it's the left side is HTML and
JavaScript and then the right side is
the result so you you know there's two
components today oh I see I said how do
you know gonna make it and then they're
two right sitting here that's what it's
doing so that's an embedded notebook
then what is that doing okay so that's
the embedded notebook embedded in a web
page and on the left is the code that
corresponds to it right and this and
presumably that's the actual that's
yawns yawns notebook around this public
right isn't this neat this is really the
I mean that documentation I just saw
that I think is the you know that's I
think this is a really good way to do
that and you know you get open and
closed cells you got the whole whole
whole ball of wax
what are we showing here it's it's a
implementation that we have in the
external box tracker which showcases the
same thing well that's the same thing
that's nice that's an iframe that's
that's the old technology that isn't
interesting that the case where we
we tried to kneel one but there were
some issues so that it's not it's not a
hundred percent bug free yet but it's
getting closer I think that this is an
example I'm gonna bring up here I think
this has an example
it's this an example I know why that's
spinning like that that this is not an
example either yeah okay so there's a
that's an example of a but they don't
think that this is an example where the
caching is not enabled properly
right and this is a very old notebook
this is probably a notebook from 25
years ago that we're not yet making
available there but um you know that the
fact that this work there's a generic
webpage and this is a notebook from 25
years ago so you know all bets are off
in terms of what's going on here but I
think we can you know it looks horrible
but but you know this probably hasn't
been rendered in 25 years
so stop interactive rendering okay
did something
but whatever um
but that's that's the idea I mean a
modern notebook should render very
nicely that way um okay yeah we'll we'll
wrap it very soon here um
ah yeah the the yes so though odds is
complaining that the crowd coats thing
that has been fixed it no longer
consumes cloud credits or won't do in
152 finally but it isn't even now I
think it is not consuming them um
and I think cloud deployed
the bar at the bottom people don't like
that yeah you will be able to get a
subscription that removes that bar
okay it's a completely different topic
here and the last one I think we should
address for tonight
um okay actually another question from
Ethan here The Notebook encoder and
better is cool does it work with longer
running and larger manipulates so the
answer is I think no in the sense that
the okay the notebook and better doesn't
care about that the question is whether
the account and the cloud that you have
behind it is enabled for those things so
if you have a private cloud for example
you can enable it to grind itself like
crazy on a manipulate if you're using
our public cloud there are limitations
because you know for load-balancing
reasons there are limitations and if
it's published and it's going to you
know you can't have some random
manipulate to take over all the
resources of our cloud for as you know
some users publish notebook so that's an
issue there but I would say that that so
I don't think we're solving the longer
running manipulates thing it will be
interesting to know what what people are
seeing with that and um and you know
what people wanted I I don't know a good
solution to that because ultimately you
know it's going to it's going to grind a
CPU and it's that you know in the end
that's going to be in somebody's account
I there's a question there about load
balancing for the cloud nobody on this
call has anything to do with that is you
so first I know but that's a good thing
to talk about and actually if somebody
could add that to the cloud development
meeting please um Raj maybe you could
I'll pass it along to Matt Thanks um
okay a final question here was from Ian
asking about orders of magnitude
slowdown in computation speeds involving
quantity variables I think we don't have
the right set of people here to talk
about that um that is something that
unless maybe we do maybe Jose can say
something Jose has been completely
silent it's not been his his topics
particularly but term right um
yeah I mean go ahead yeah so we are
working on improving quantity is speed
and it has been moving in in several
steps the first one was to eliminate any
connection to to the perform of a
service because they were still being
connected for some parts of
interpretation and and so on and and now
we will be improving the speed by moving
some parts to faster C code right good
what's the timeframe for that is that a
12-1 thing no twelve one we are working
now I mean Nick and I are work on
working on on date intervals and they'd
functionality so probably after that we
will go back to please okay the um okay
I think every I think it's getting late
here I gotta get to work on some other
things actually but we thought this I
mean I think this experiment you know
there's the first time we're doing one
of these discussions about user surfaced
issues and this has been helpful to us I
think hopefully it's been helpful to to
focus on the live stream to UM and okay
we've got a pronunciation guide for za
bolts his name which I which I will look
at here um and okay we will bring this
up just as I lost oh my gosh
okay I should be able to read IPA look
in Sam's at this essay zabo okay sabitch
all right sab sab Oh
sbatch thank you okay all right very
good um okay I will try and get that
right in future I appreciate that the
guide um the okay well thanks everybody
and we'll we'll do this again much
appreciated and please in terms of maybe
we should just say how to surface
questions that people want to address on
this live stream what's the mean we've
been doing kind of freeform on the live
stream but I think we we also in terms
of building the agenda can anybody say
how people should try and describe
things that can be prioritized in the
agenda well I started out making the
agenda based on the community post I did
so I tried to get you know issues there
but then I think the Chad comments kind
of took off after that so okay like we
lack issues to look at but it's it's
kind of like you know who's no but I
think the important question our note is
that you know we have hundreds of
developers right so so it's some you
know making sure the right people are in
this meeting if I would suggest going
area by area like we can you know we've
discussed input export right but we
could go and dive into more detail in
that side work right so that will be
useful if people have particular kinds
of areas amande we happen to have many
people here were reasonably expert in
that the issues that we're talking about
but you know that things people could
have poked at which we just wouldn't
have had anybody here to discuss so we
also we also have a developer conference
coming up in case people want attendance
that's true that's next you want holes
it's in like late October October 20th
or something 31st okay okay so that's
that that's the real place if you really
want to find out what's going on and
make your case in person a good fraction
of our developers show up to that or at
least representatives of most of the
teams show up and and they're often
recorder too so if you cannot attend
always watch them and you know certain
relevant areas you can see what's going
on okay well thanks all and gonna sign
off much appreciative we'll be back
another time okay bye-bye